au pouvoir merci monsieur le garde des
sceaux la palette à monsieur philippe
armand partant merci monsieur le
président ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre de l'agriculture
depuis plus de 4 ans vous nous expliquer
avec conviction que le gouvernement
oeuvre en faveur des agriculteurs
mais les mesures annoncées sont toujours
saupoudré et ne répondent pas aux enjeux
structurels des filières agricoles et
viticoles
si le gouvernement auquel vous
appartenez
c'est faire preuve d'inconstance les
exploitants agricoles se veut faire
preuve de constance et dénonce
inlassablement les prix divisé par deux
en 40 ans malgré la qualité grandissante
des produits les revenus insuffisants
malgré un travail acharné les retraites
nettement insuffisante pour vivre
décemment
la place amoindri de l'agriculture
française sur les marchés mondiaux les
excès de contrôle et de charge les
incertitudes toujours d'actualité sur
l'utilisation des produits
phytosanitaires les problèmes de
l'élevage toujours plus prégnant ou
encore la grande instabilité
réglementaire que produit l'opulence de
texte bref une situation mauvaise et
injuste qui ne correspond pas aux
nombreux atouts de l'agriculture
française en ce début d'année qui
devrait redonner l'espérance allez vous
comprendre monsieur le ministre il faut
élaborer un plan d'ensemble qui soient
pérennes qu'il faut rendre aux
agriculteurs la liberté d'entreprendre
notamment réduisant les charges et les
normes et en favorisant la transmission
et l'innovation qu'il faut recomposer
les marchés en facilitant d'une part les
circuits directs aux profits et des
agriculteurs et des consommateurs
d'autre part en fixant des règles
claires pour la négociation des prix et
des contrats avec la grande distribution
ont résumé comprendre que pour
redistribuer la richesse
il faut d'abord l'avoir laissée secret
alors monsieur le ministre attend vos
propositions
merci la parole est un monsieur stéphane
le foll ministre de l'agriculture de
l'agro alimentaire eda foreurs se
présente ce député je crains que en deux
minutes
minutes c'est ça j'ai du mal à répondre
à la totalité de la question qui m'est
posée
je voulais simplement vous rappeler
monsieur le député que sur la question
par exemple de l'allègement des charges
nous en sommes à 1 milliard 600 millions
d'euros que jamais il n'a été baissé
autant les charges pour l'agriculture
que sous ce gouvernement
premier constat c'est souvent une
demande que vous faites je vous réponds
vous avez parlé comme toujours de la
question des normes
quand je suis arrivé il ya eu aucune sur
transposition des normes européennes
par contre nous avons facilité un
certain nombre de mesures nouvelles pour
justement simplifier l'application à
certaines normes
je pense en particulier sur les
procédures d'enregistrement qui ont été
mises dans le cadre de la procédure des
établissements classés qui n'existe pas
et qui sont aujourd'hui très utile en
particulier dans les départements
d'élevage
vous avez évoqué la modernisation mais
si je prends le plan de modernisation
dans les bâtiments d'élevage
c'est plus de 1 milliard d'euros
d'investis avec 350 millions liée à la
fois à l'état et aux régions qui
aujourd'hui sont investis si vous voulez
penser à l'avenir de l'agriculture
monsieur le député s'est pas simplement
en évoquant les charges sociales ou la
question des normes si en essayant de
penser une agriculture qui va être
compétitifs parce qu'elle va intégrer
des contraintes environnementales non
pas comme des contraintes mais comme des
atouts je voyais il ya quelques jours
une un résultat d'un d'un institut
technique qui s'appelle terra innovia
sur les oléoprotéagineux qu'est ce que
dit cet institut technique c'est qu'un
associant la production de colza avec
une légumineuse en l'occurrence de la
féverole on faisait baisser de 20%
le recours aux phytosanitaires on
faisait baisser de 30% les herbicides et
on augmentait la production monsieur le
député le sens de l'agroécologie c'est
de con de faire en sorte de combiner la
performance économique et la performance
écologique